présente c'est lives good la vie est
belle en français c'est bien Mo il forme
un couple fusionnel lives good 12 ans
ongre belge aux origines
germano-française et Adib 42 ans
franco-égyptien et plégique de naissance
c'est un guerrier donc donc très très
bon mental pour la
compétition même pour la vie de tous les
jours c'est c'est un
bonheur qure fois par semaine le duo
révise ses gammes le
ou plutôt le trio composé avec Julien
j'ai l'objectif de pouvoir préparer
échauffer son cheval avant que lui
monte donc du coup pour mettre en place
un peu tous les petits réglages les
codes qu'on a mis en
place
Adib un problème d'émiplégie côté droit
donc il est un petit peu plus fragile de
ce côté là le cheval dont le déborde un
petit peu parfois du côté droit et le
but du school rider qui est valide c'est
de rétablir de la symétrie pour mettre
le cheval dans la rectitude et le
confort un passage obligé pour réaliser
une séance efficace pour moi le cheval
là il commence à être bien on va pouvoir
mettre Adib dessus ça me donne aussi le
fait les S la sensation visuelle et
avant de monter à cheval et pour good un
trio a bien d'autres avantages ah bah il
a beaucoup plus de
[Rires]
câ
recule pas ta main droite là voilà
laisse le
passer là il est
top moi j'apporte l'œil du juge en fait
c'est-à-dire un œil critique sur la
façon de fonctionner du cheval sur son
niveau de relaxation d'harmonie avec le
cavalier les attitudes les orientations
du Fal la dynamique l'équilibre tout ce
qu'on veut voir en compétition celui qui
regarde doit pas avoir l'impression que
ça ça sent la sueur ça doit paraître
facile comme tout ce qui est de haut
niveau on doit avoir l'impression que
c'est simple alors qu'en fait ça l''est
pas du tout c'est ça l'idée l'histoire
d'adiib est intimement lié au monde
desquin c'est d'ailleurs grâce à lui que
s'est révélé son handicap je suis né au
Nigéria ma maman faisant du cheval m'a
mis à cheval pour me promener comme tout
enfant mais j'étais en couche culote et
c'est également comme ça qu'ils ont
découvert mon handicap à cheval je
tombais toujours du côté gauche
peut-être que c'est grâce au que
j'accepte plus mon handicap et que
j'arrive à le à le partager à
partager un grand
public conférencier ambassadeur de son
sport ad B décrocher le titre de
champion de France en novembre dernier
classé 13e mondial il devait concourir
pour la France mais la Fédération
internationale lui a proposé de
représenter les couleurs égyptiennes une
chance exceptionnelle à ses yeux il y a
pas beaucoup des athlètes qui ont eu
cette occasion là de représenter ces
deux nations à des jeux olympiques ou
paralympiques pour moi c'est très
symbolique que ça soit pour pour
représenter mes deux origines et
finalement finalement les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques c'est ça
c'est le sport la performance d'un côté
mais aussi tout ce qui est paix et
fraternité entre pays prochaine étape
une potentielle compétition au Qatar en
février c'est bien mon petit kiki en
attendant l'équipe poursuit eusement sa
préparation